salut et bienvenue aux mâles masqué il
mal masqué ohé ohé cette vidéo m lorgues
aujourd'hui on fait une malle casse-tête
escape game est un concept qui n'existe
pas qui a l'air trop stylé alors on n'a
pas fait fabriquer pour moi c'est
bienvenue aux grains qui nous l'a prête
pour qu'on vive l'expérience en thermale
elle se fait à plusieurs elle a même été
pensé pour être fait de manière
familiale moi je vais m'y attaquer avec
tous mes amis qui vivent dans ma tête et
on va essayer de résoudre ça en moins
d'une heure voir si c'est possible j'ai
hâte de voir ce qui est à l'intérieur
mais avant que cette vidéo commence
laissez moi vous dire que
j'ai quelque chose à vous présenter un
partenariat un partenariat exactement le
hic c'est incroyable ou pas et pourquoi
en faire un partenariat dans cette vidéo
dans d'autres vidéos dites moi tout loïc
et bien c'est pour financer les gros
projets tels que les grosses banques et
les matières grises et des choses comme
ça va bien pas moi c'était vraiment pour
mes vacances de cet hiver ah oui en vrai
c'est pour financer les matières grises
les cabinets curieuse où vous ne voyez
jamais de placement de produits dedans
et aussi pour les gros cast est énorme
comme ça parce que ça j'imagine très
bien quatre à fabriquer ça vaut une
c'est des petites fortunes mais c'est
des bijoux et c'est trop beau et on en a
qui est en préparation et que vous allez
voir dans quelques semaines mois loïc
événement partenariat du coup cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par je vais faire
comme tout le monde recha de legends ce
jeu a changé le visage du jeu vidéo sur
mobile pour toujours si vous faites pas
partie de cette révolution alors c'est
que vous êtes sur la touche ou que vous
avez acheté un forfait récemment un
forfait forfait genre tu étais pas
encore connectés à internet hélas à un
forfait internet quoi genre tu étais pas
sur internet
réd shadow les jo je vous propose
désormais de plus en plus de bosses dure
à affronter comme si un gala roth par
exemple il est différent des autres boss
il est comme un paladin avec la mission
de garde et non pas des boutons mais des
potions arcade vous pouvez dés prendre
si vous le battez ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est pas très compliqué mais vous devez
prêt pour ces attaques tissir gala roth
est trop facile pour vous vous pouvez
tester vos limites dans les batailles
avec d'autres joueurs dans l'arène
directement en plus ce mois-ci raid un
programme chargé d'évènements comme
halloween qui vous donnera l'occasion de
gagner des grosses récompenses de jouer
des tournois contre d'autres joueurs des
événements spéciaux fragments pour
obtenir de tout nouveaux champions
légendaires dont un champion d'halloween
très chevelu personnellement j'aime bien
l'aspect terrifiant des bosses là ils
sont vraiment sinistre bref c'est le
meilleur moment pour commencer à jouer à
rennes celle de legends donc n'hésitez
pas le lien est dans la description est
juste en cliquant dessus ou en scannant
le qr code ici si vous êtes un nouveau
joueur vous obtiendrez votre champion
épique et shawn rude 200000 d'argent un
boost xp nous recharge d'énergie un
éclat antic avant même de commencer à
jouer moi je retourne me prendre la tête
on attaque tout de suite avec le brief
par ordre de mission
si vous recevez ce que je sais que vous
avez été sélectionné parmi les plus
prometteuses pour participer à l'examen
final de notre programme de formation
contre pourquoi on sélectionne à chaque
fois et que c'est pas des trucs simples
déguiseront dans des cercles vous avez
encore avant le titre d'agent de
première classe aujourd'hui vous
affrontez le missiles atomiques des
lignes un loup remporté elle veut nous
avons basé notre épreuve sera qu'il
dérobait une agente pôle chimique a
filtré dans l'aéroport d'orly avec une
substance il a mal exposé vous serez
recalés est mort c'est violent un parent
comptant en cas d'échec sur ce bon
courage souvenez-vous lambiner trop
c'est l'explosion voyant même pas ce
qu'il ya derrière on regarde si à part
peut-être transparence vite fait au vol
ça ce sera fait on a quand même des
chiffres 20 octobre 1962 voyons cette
malle un cadenas il semble le réel oui
ok cor fdb
on s'en fiche ça c'est notre normal
corse a aussi incarné avec une clé qui
va probablement ouvrir un autre cannes
là qu'est ce qu'on a sur les côtés ça
c'est un fauqué menace à sa bouche et
voilà ça c'est ouvert allez hop là donc
ça c'est les faux qu'elle n'a dans la 1
qui ouvert ici ça c'est déjà pas mal
ok là c'est un break en larmes dirait un
chiffre séquencier derrière on a des
petites choses ça se trouvera pas ça non
hôtel 07 02 d'accord là il ya un truc
bizarre
ça ça me servira c'est sûr quand on ne
sait pas puis la y ait une autre série
de chiffres les chiffres un peu partout
toccata quatre salaires des débris kahn
n'a retenu est ce que j'essaierai pas
les cadenas qui correspond aux
étiquettes là c'est 12 35 parce que je
mettrais pas un petit 12,35 ici
directement
12,3
cinq
exactement pas ça du tout
là il ya le 00 07
essayez aussi
cessa lieu
6 066 n'en
c6696 09 je les sigles et en os x 6 6 0
9 donc le on peut le pape est ici
plus et le 07 02 je n'ai pas fait sur
0,7
0,2 non et ça ralentit fa bow
et 1980 et je viens de voir je vais le
laisser comme ça j'aurais fait toutes
les combinaisons
du coup logiquement j'aurais dû réussir
à ouvrir donc je pense que je suis pas
aligné avec lui 07 02
07 sec 2 c'est lui ok donc ses 7 4 8 5
que j'ai pas fait et le 66 09 aussi je
l'essayé l'accident 6,09
donc pour l'instant le 66 09 que j'ai
cru que j'avais tri quelle game en
faisant en sorte de pâles lire à
l'envers peut-être faut le dire à
lorient 60 99 si c'est ça gérer de ce
métier je décide de ne jamais devenir
agent secret
je n'ai pas fini ma phrase à moi qui
souffre du conseil ça compte pas donc il
me reste celui ci alors là si ils ont
pas été malin parce que c'est vraiment
une erreur de la part des chefs des
agents secrets de mettre la clé du
cadenas sur le cadenas faut pas faire ça
en fait je suis très déçu du court et
pas une clé qui est caché là tu saoules
me permettrai de l'ouvrir non
j'ai tout un bloc
ça c'est vraiment vie c'est oui donc il
faut vraiment l'ouvrir aux riches
je pense que c'est de ce côté là que
j'ai passé moins de temps
au niveau des poignets
ah la vache tu es sûre dit le mec n'a
pas trouvé depuis 20 minutes alors
c'était triki parce que c'était pas
accessible de ce côté là et la claque
les ne fonctionne pas zut
en plus de ça pour rire mais
alors comment elle marche la clé qui
n'ouvre pas parce que ça va être un truc
classique est évidemment
non cette clé ne l'ouvrent pas donc il
faut que je trouve autre chose à faire
je plaisante ça ouvre évidemment à tech
paniqué on ouvre la bestiole
tin tin tin tin tin
ab non
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'était mauvais très marrant c'était
marrant
mais bon c'est déjà pas beaucoup ce qui
est à nous et à nous ce qui est à vous
est négociable très drôle ok il ya des
trucs de partout je n'imaginais pas du
tout ça dedans france et russes français
et russes allumé amorcé en poule parfait
ça c'est parfait alors qu'est ce qu'il
ya là là il ya des petits trucs je
touche à rien je sais pas à quoi ça
correspond
là non plus là non plus l'assassin lève
il ya une poupée russe osz et de
l'impression 3d ça c'est un labyrinthe
aveugle
de partir d'un mauvais ce soit la
caisse qu'on a
ça je suis pas mauvais à ce genre de
trucs oui more heroes 2 secondes un
[ __ ] mais ça ne s'arrête jamais en
fait plus ces poubelles russe fait
plaisir avec des accents c'est la
première fois que j'entends faire un
accent correct j'étais assez whaou hop
hop hop et voilà qu'est ce qu'on a ici
on a un fusible et là apparemment il
faudrait mettre un fusible alors
attendez j'observe quand même ce qu'on a
à l'intérieur tout ça voilà c'est
incroyable ce que c'est j'entends ta
mère on pose le fusible
de prendre un coup de jus ça s'est
allumée loupiotes loupiotes loupiotes
loupiotes voilà là c'est quoi ces des
boutons
j'ai peur que ça vaut 4 truc rouge donc
il va falloir trouver une combinaison
c'est ça bon je lève tous les appuis
d'accord donc ils comptent au et
calme-toi un joseph il doit y avoir un
indice quelque part il y avait tout un
truc là derrière
des sur nos peurs d'une séquence du saas
que via un petit excusez moi le hic la
gare mais y en a qui bossent via le
bouton noir aussi mais oui donc il ya
vraiment une séquence a trouvé ça
c'était le haut parleur
là il ya un code avec une clé la clé de
la clé de telle heure il y avait une clé
que j'avais trouvé aussi
il y avait celle ci il y avait celle ci
mais celle ci elle ne nous a jamais
servi ne l'oublions pas cette clé bon
elle ne va clairement pas là dedans mais
c'est important de ne pas l'oublier
parce qu'apprendre dit oui tu fouilles
paas et blablabla tu explores pas
maintenant que j'explore tout le monde
moi ce que je pourrais trouver cette
séquence là déconnecté allumé amorcé ma
main
à ma tante
voire à mecteau [ __ ] on dirait harry
potter
mais qd haut placés et après c'est un
truc comme le début pis après cpe de
bigby pepy pc sa place et fusibles ça
c'est fait ok voir abah abah le groupe
ces étapes abbas a de
l'intérêt de j'imagine voilà étape deux
séquences à allumer à deux allumés à 2 à
oui assez un allumé 1 2 3 le n 1 verset
et y est yat y est y est et 4 elle met 1
2 3 et 4 est achetée ou achat est pressé
pressé
conques à conca bouton c'est ce goût et
ça c'est à dire que
mpmp et droite à nîmes 1 2 3 4 et j'ai
pressé bouton gauche et droite
elle est en même temps
ah bah si haye hélas à allumer le vert
ok donc ça ça doit vouloir dire étape
puisque c'est le même mot ah bah ça
voulait dire deux bébés l on ne l'a
jamais traduit la bbl s'éteindre
éteindre lui lui c'était le poids
éteindre en poules en poule 3 éteindre
en poule 3 ça c'était 4 je me souviens 4
appuyé compter à ses boutons et ça ça
veut dire gauche
s'est allumé ça ça veut dire étape ça
veut dire trois bébés elle ça veut dire
éteindre ça c'est en poule une
en plus une des kpi c'était quoi ça tpn
c3 allumé trois et
ça ça veut dire quatre annulé 3 et 4 et
ça veut dire appuyé bouton gauche et
droite
oui c'est bon et enfin étape 4
jean-jacques donc éteindre en poule 2
en poule 2 en plus de 4
à lui mais ça c'est en poule une
et appuyer bouton ça c'est droite chez
afi oui
oui ça développe
ou c'est chaud
très bizarre dit comme ça c'est chaud oh
il ya du document là mon frère il ya un
petit coup de téléphone à passer il ya
des petites fiches qui prennent une vie
à lire toujours très pratique ça avec
des symboles très étrange derrière qui
ne sont pas toujours les mêmes
d'ailleurs ils ceux qui ne sont pas
cyclique là il ya de la ja de la docte à
vue basse a appris hier on a traduit
tout ce qu'ils avaient à traduire ici
donc ça c'est bon ça c'est bon à ça ça
me parle c'est ce qu'on a derrière ça
c'est des noms des nationalités des
dates de naissance nous savons que les
rouges ont aussi des dossiers sur les
nôtres il ya une grosse fuite et nous
savons désormais que la moitié des
agences sont des agents doubles mais on
peut retourner ça contre chercher des
disparités dans leur dossier si vous les
trouvez il n'accumule pas leurs propres
agents doivent avoir des fausses fiches
essayé de contacter ceux qui nous sont
restés fidèles
ok ça c'est les fiches et du coup si
elle se trouve paul étrillé par rapport
aux symboles qui est derrière ça c'est
un symbole
c'est pas de même c'est pas le même
c'est à ne sait jamais les mêmes ce
n'est jamais les mêmes sait jamais les
mains ok qu'est ce qu'il dit ce document
la connexion d amorçage variable selon
les modèles l'ag ça se fait un petit
point on a ce qu'il ya derrière qui
donnait des ampoules bleues ou blanches
on a toute ses fiches on a ça qui
correspond à ce qu'il ya derrière ça qui
correspond à ce qu'il ya derrière qu'est
ce que je vais vouloir rencontrer non je
vais vouloir les contacter je vais
vouloir les contacter pour les contacter
je prends ça l'aï dit c'est peut-être
les numéros de téléphone pour les
contacter ou c'est peut-être ici qu'il
ya des numéros de téléphone
comment on peut savoir des disparités
entre eux aussi leurs 7 080 3 000 cas un
français françaises anglaises allemandes
géante les rouges ont aussi des dossiers
sur les notes mais il ya une grosse
fuite et nous savons désormais que la
moitié sont des agents doubles doivent
avoir des fausses fiches
parfois tendues mais incriminé comment
on incrimine quelqu'un
attends les tampons ils sont pas mis au
même endroit je vais voir s'il y en a
autant à droite qu'à gauche
gauche gauche droite gauche droite
gauche droite gauche droite gauche la
plus à gauche qu'à droite quand même ils
ont dit la moitié donc ça peut pas être
ça imaginons que je fasse le que
j'appelle jean moulin peut s'utiliser
français
reçoit rien de spécial
12h33 nous sommes au courant parce que
les trucs de condensats tu as tout c'est
trop tôt là je pense
je vais quoi est-ce que j'ai des
symboles ici ce que je suis pas en train
de focaliser là par erreur
je pense qu'il faut appeler quelqu'un
alors je n'arrive pas à petit a il est
séparé le tibet
comprendre comment je les appelle ce que
l'on peut mettre les cartes deux par
deux en imaginant les symboles nom
[Musique]
ferait pas de mal je suis allée aux
toilettes savoir avec le temps c'est un
peu écoulée faut que je me speed est
bien de penser que j'ai pas couper la
gopro donc loïc si tu peux vraiment
effacer complètement ses rushs que
personne ne puisse jamais les retrouver
s'il te plait je cherche quelque chose
de différent sion
derrière et il ya ces logos là qui me
met me mette à mal je me demande ce
n'est pas juste une fausse piste pour je
sais pas comment le dire poliment pour
m'embêter pour magath sait si tel est le
cas ça fonctionne très bien peut-être on
est à gauche s'était tourné à droite
peut-être deux face à face avec les
têtes sur les photos il faut que je
regarde au moins six parce que si je les
ai classé dans le
dans le bon sens semble vouloir
[Musique]
le nom de famille n'est pas toujours
bien écrit je suis vraiment pin vieille
merde je vais vous savez quoi je vais
prendre la bombe et je vais me la faire
sauter je me suis je me détestais
colombo pas columbus combelongue lui le
je sais pas quoi là tu as mon cerveau
corriger des erreurs mais je déteste mon
cerveau moulin il était bon je les vues
de thaler james bande d'onde ou monde
donc ça va être que sur les noms
compliqués
moi c'est
lié va nord on arrive aux 15 minutes un
fatidique on vérifie tous les logos il
ya bien marqué gros en anglais we 15-12
1928 c'est faux
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé un truc avec une batte
immense compagne j'ai trouvé un truc par
rapport aux non il m'en feront pas de
peut-être les nationalités
ah [ __ ] je crois que c'est lui 8
à celui
de chaque fois donc c'est assez les
fosses à célébrer essayé de contacter
ceux qui nous sont restés fidèles donc
c'est eux qu'il faut que je contacte 6
et 4 10 et 9 19 20 21 bons s'avère trop
bizarre de les additionner
mais je vais le faire quand même oui les
quatre fromages
dans dix minutes merci
pizza rien rien à voir que je les
appelle maintenant bien positionnés d
heidi
020 de
4,6 [ __ ] c'était tout père relève qu'à
0 2 4 6 9
je suis une crotte en exploration est ce
qu'on pourra retenir ça vous pouvez le
mettre dans les commentaires fabriquer
une crotte d'expo au
lycée tous ces styles mairesse tout sept
minutes moi je vous parle plus
personnellement ça s'ouvre pas ça ça
permet de voir des choses
alors ça fait des numéros c'est
incroyable cette histoire n'a qu'à
regarder ça pendant cinq minutes 50
98 hockey à l'oratoire jeu les mettre
dans l'ordre de trucs 4 6 9
comment un côté très magique et ce à la
lumière se reflète ça c'est 1 2
[Musique]
pour
les 24 98
sa
page en alcool tél
grain
explosion dans h - plus loin minutes
[ __ ] c'était ce à quoi notre 9,8
maintenance vite
007 métal ans a décroché aussi
impeccable
bonjour
je vous en prie oui ben même que le fion
oui s'il te plaît
du coup
[Musique]
chez moi
[ __ ] parle pas en même temps ouais
ouais ouais mais il faut que je rappe et
le masseur j'ai pas tout retenu du
premier coup
à l'espace on rappelle
on est mort mais on rappelle
anderson des grands
[Musique]
noms
je n'entends pas parce que soi disant
j'ai échoué une frustration terrible ok
la bombe et à 0 mais parce que je suis
allé aux toilettes ça a dû me prendre à
peu près une demi heure donc on
considère qu' il reste une demi heure
avec c'est pour ça qu'elle souhaite pas
en tout cas je continue
interrupteur
ce résistance bleue je passe derrière
messieurs j'imagine que ça ça sert à
quelque chose ça me sert à donner les
couleurs ça c'est le petit point
lumineux donc ça me donne le sens
d'accord on a dit interrupteur un
interrupteur c'est quoi un interrupteur
c'est qui un interrupteur c'est ça un
interrupteur
interrupteur il est là sur résistance
bleue donc c'est celui qui est le plus à
droite sur celui qui est tout au milieu
tac
ok
ok ça c'est branché ensuite c'était
diodes sur ampoules verte diodes
ampoules verte 3e en partant de la
gauche oui sur le premier oui ensuite
c'était bv sur cb bvbc bobines bobines
verte mobile vers ho
marche pas cette histoire bv sur cb
bobine verte sur
condensateurs bleus 1 ça marche pas du
tout bv sur cb passer le câble rouge
quoi bv sur cb il ya plein de trucs qui
sont pas branchés en plus il m'en reste
du câblage
bv bobines verte
[Musique]
quelque chose la bobine vertes avaient
déjà
une bobine verte elle est déjà sur le
conte à cette heure bleue
verte au pire
c'est un bleu bobines bleus marchait
qu'on a cet or vert
bobines bleus avec concentrent dans
cette heure à [ __ ] bobines blum auteur
à la la il y en a pas qu'un ces
variables ses marques et fabien pour
m'acheter un cerveau envoyé cerveau aux
6-12 deux bobines bleus à moteur vert
moteur vert 2ème en partant du
barthésienne en partant du bas
maintenant 4e en partant du haut c'est
venez avec moi les gars
quatrième en partant du haut c'est une
résistance verte c'est résistance verte
à alimentation bleus avant dernier en
partant à droite là
ok ensuite détonateur bleus on n'a pas
ça donc c'est forcément en bleu donc ça
va être le dernier
tout dernier est du coup
en toute logique
celui ci
il va là
[Musique]
c'est déjà et c'est désamorcer on risque
plus rien parce que c'était 1 0 c'est un
peu comme le dernier pour 113 phone des
fois ça dure un peu longtemps ça serait
bien un petit groupe c'est un certificat
diplôme d'agent première classe alors
voici une première classe éco quand même
vu le procès verbal de l'examen
ouverture de la malle diplôme agents du
crou un agent secret de l'état
j'ai un permis de tuer le feu bien bien
fatwa prochaine mission on sait pas et
ben c'était vraiment stylé le concept
est magnifique la boîte est magnifique
j'ai kiffé ça je regrette un truc on
aurait dû le faire à plusieurs on aurait
dû chauffer organisé c'est un peu plus
j'ai pas pensé mais je crois que ça
aurait été rigolo de le faire peut-être
avec toi louis
tin tin tin de sauter le lien moi non
mais attends c'était c'était c'était
super cool rester là j'ai un dernier
truc à vous dire lui qui dit tu vas
qu'on avait dit ouais faut qu'on pense à
faire là où trop de cette vidéo que je
suis en train de monter celle que tu es
en train de monter là du coup tu l'as
outreau et ben non ok bien peut-être je
vais la faire alors ok merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci encore
à rennes shadow legends d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo vous retrouver le
jeu le jeu pas le jeu en lien dans la
description et puis n'oubliez pas ce
sont les dernières dates de spectacles
là par exemple je suis à toulouse après
je suis à liége après à bruxelles c'est
déjà complet et c'est jusqu'au zénith de
paris plus beaucoup de place et la
rochelle et après c'est terminé pour ce
spectacle tu viens zénith de paris bien
sûr je serai là et grâce à elle commente
a pris la place des liens dans la
description des composites et sur le
site sur le site sur les six philippins
je vérifierai ton nom prenez soin de
vous à très bientôt ciao